the world is on
fire monar was there in San
Francisco when the whole city was coming
down these guys were taking pictures
like they'd been waiting for
it you think that your father was
working for them this stuff wasn't as
safe who are they what's
Monarch there's
a this is the world we live in monsters
are an inescapable
reality those files belong to us and
they are more important than you could
possibly
imagine this is going to give me
nightmares
now you can choke down that Monarch
lie about your father disappearing
with or we can find out what really
happened before it's too
[Music]
late oh my God go go go this world it's
not ours believe
me is so much more vast than we could
possibly
imagine these monsters and Monarch have
taken everything from
me no
more the world is on fire if you want to
save millions of lives we can can use
some
[Music]
help